y como todos los días en France 24
dedicamos un espacio a la salud mar
bienvenida Buenos días María Clara y hoy
vamos a hablar de España porque ayer
jueves aprobaron dos leyes importantes
una la ley del aborto y otra la llamada
ley trans explíquenos En qué consiste
pues son las reformas que me regulan
varias cosas pero que tienen muchas
implicaciones también sobre la salud de
las personas y de las mujeres y en eso
nos vamos a centrar en este espacio
empezamos con la reforma a la ley del
aborto no que recordemos que ya era
legal en España desde hace 13 años pero
que se han introducido algunos cambios
para solucionar sobre todo problemas de
acceso a este servicio quizás el punto
más importante es que jóvenes de 16 y 17
años puedan Acceder al servicio de
aborto de interrupción Perdón del
embarazo sin consentimiento parental
Para evitar Pues según sus Defensores
que vayan a abortar de formas
clandestinas si su familia no les apoya
en decisión también se elimina el
periodo de reflexión de tres días que
solía ser obligatorio y el recibimiento
también obligatorio de un sobre sobre
información legal sobre ayudas a la
maternidad cosa que había despertado
polémica por ejemplo en la comunidad de
Madrid donde habían además pues dado
información religiosa y cuéntanos Qué
significa ese periodo de reflexión es un
periodo de reflexión en el que la mujer
tenía que llegar primero a decir que
quería abortar y después tenía que
esperar tres días para volver a reiterar
esa información Entonces digamos que hay
muchas veces se perdió un tiempo
importante para muchas mujeres sobre
todo si estaban en el límite digamos de
la de la del término legal para abortar
otra otra de las de las reglas que se ha
incluido es el registro de objetores de
conciencia el principal problema Por
ejemplo de acceso al aborto era que
muchos servicios públicos que deberían
estar ofertando este servicio Pues de
clase declaraban objetores de conciencia
que no querer practicarlo entonces
muchas mujeres tenían por ejemplo que
desplazarse hasta clínicas privadas si
no existían en sus vecindades de sus
pues pasa mucho en poblaciones más
Rurales digamos y eso también provocaba
mucho retrasos muchos problemas de
acceso Y por último también la
incompatibilidad entre ser objetor y
formar parte de un comité clínico que
tome decisiones sobre casos concretos de
aborto entonces bueno estas han sido
digamos las las reformas principales que
se han incluido y hay otra gran reforma
y es que se van a permitir las
incapacidades por dolores menstruales
que es un tema que hemos tratado aquí en
La Crónica de salud de manera reiterada
y que además hace que España sea el
primer país europeo en permitirla En qué
consiste esto pues se recoge como decías
en muy pocos países Aunque de hecho en
Italia también se recoge dentro de la
oeste de la Unión Europea está baja
menstrual Pero es verdad que en el resto
de países no y en la mayoría del mundo
tampoco En qué cómo se va a tramitar
esta ley pues primero se necesita un
diagnóstico previo de patología un
diagnóstico previo de enfermedad No qué
es lo que provoca esta dismenorrea que
un nombre técnico de los dolores
menstruales primero Pues que si la regla
causa recordemoslo dolores
incapacitantes no es normal deberíamos
acudir a uno médico y encontrar Qué es
lo que está haciendo este tipo de
dolores por ejemplo la endometriosis es
una enfermedad que aqueja a un 10% más o
menos de la población quistes en los
ovarios también puede ser uno de los
motivos que estén detrás de estas reglas
dolorosas uno de los cambios además de
esta ley Es que este subsidio digamos
por la baja laboral se va a dar desde el
primer día eso que pasaba antes estaba a
partir del cuarto día normalmente con
los dolores menstruales en el cuarto día
ya no aquejan a la persona Entonces eso
provocaba que hubiera diferencias
salariales importantes entre hombres y
mujeres no si al final cada mes se
perdían dos días por ejemplo de salario
Pues hay una desigualdad al final de mes
que se va acumulando también con los
años y esta ley intenta pues igualar el
terreno de juego en este sentido
buscamos las cifras de mujeres que
reportan dolores menstruales en España
por cada mil habitantes solo cifras
hasta 2017 Pero ha ido aumentando se ve
desde 2011 una de las hipótesis que
puede aumentar a raíz de que pues se
habla más O sea puesto sobre la mesa
precisamente un dolor que solía estar
tradicionalmente olvidado las cifras de
2017 las últimas que hemos encontrado
hablan de 14,32 mujeres por cada mil
habitantes lo podemos trasladar
Aproximadamente a 14,32 mujeres por 500
mujeres también no entendiendo que es
aproximadamente el 50% de la población
es una prevalencia relativamente alta y
bueno es un paso hacia reconocer estos
Dolores que hasta hace nada no se tenían
ni siquiera en cuenta y no solo se dio
un paso en ese sentido sino que también
se aprobó la llamada ley trans esto
luego de que Escocia por ejemplo estuvo
en una polémica que terminó con la
salida de la ministra principal Nicolás
quien defendió flexibilizar las leyes
para que las personas puedan cambiarse
de sexo legalmente precisamente eso es
lo que ha pasado en España no ahora con
esta de la ley trans que recoge además
muchísimos puntos no es lo único una de
las cosas que recoge es la prohibición
de la terapia de las terapias de
conversión para todas las personas lgtbi
y más prohíbe también por cierto la
modificación modificación genital para
personas intersex menores de 12 años
esto es un problema del que no hablamos
tanto por ejemplo Pero hay muchas
personas intersex es decir que nacen con
genitales digamos que no se pueden
definir fácilmente si son del sexo
femenino o masculino y son sometidas a
cirugías no por motivos de salud sino
para encajar digamos en alguno de los
dos géneros sin que la persona tenga
autonomía para decidir uno si quiere
someterse a esa cirugía y dos hacia qué
género querría o sin incluso quiere irse
hacia alguno de los dos géneros en el
espectro de lo binario Entonces eso
también va a quedar prohibido también
blinda la reproducción asistida para
mujeres lesbianas o bisexuales o mujeres
que quieran gestar solas que el gobierno
conservador del partido Popular en 2014
las había excluido del acceso a través
de la salud pública a esta reproducción
asistida pero como decías y como
mencionabas al principio quizás uno de
los puntos más importantes o que más
polémica también ha generado es lo que
se conoce como esa autodeterminación de
género Aunque la ley no use
particularmente Este término Y es que a
partir de los 14 años se podrá solicitar
el cambio de nombre y de género en los
documentos legales 14 15 años con
acompañamiento parental a partir de los
16 sin acompañamiento parental y también
sin requisitos documentales que estas
quizás una de las partes más importantes
no se tienen que Mostrar documentos por
ejemplo pues psicológicos enfermedades
no y es un paso hacia considerar que lo
trans no es una enfermedad bueno Y usted
nos va a presentar las palabras de
alguien de quién de uge que es la
portavoz de la flgtb de España
escuchemos como lo celebraba la ley
prevé la libre autodeterminación del
género el que yo pueda cambiar mi nombre
y sexo en el registro civil sin testigos
ni certificaciones
médica por lo tanto incluye la
despatologización las personas trans no
somos enfermas las personas trans
podremos ir a Registro Civil a cambiar
nuestro nombre y dni a partir de los 16
años con total libertad bueno sin duda
entonces España está dando grandes pasos
por la salud de las personas así estamos
Gracias mar por toda la información
hasta el lunes